Transcriptor: Yonara Anastacio
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Probablemente muchos de Uds.
conozcan lo que está en esta fotografía.
Sí, es Frankenstein.
Creada a principios de 1800 y considerada
una de las obras de ciencia ficción
más grandes de la historia.
Aquí resalta uno de los
personajes principales.
El científico: quien con su
creatividad y su ingenio
une varias partes de cuerpos humanos
para crear una persona
y darle vida gracias
a la energía eléctrica.
¿Se imaginan que Mary Shelley, creadora
de esta obra, se diera cuenta hoy día
de los avances tecnológicos
y científicos que ha habido?
Y no estamos hablando solamente
de trasplantes de órganos,
sino también de elaboración de prótesis,
que dan vida y esperanza a la gente.
Pues yo me siento como ese científico,
con ganas de poder utilizar la energía
e inclusive llegar a potabilizar el agua.
Desde muy pequeño me di cuenta
de la escasez de este recurso
y de la vulnerabilidad que tiene al entrar
en contacto con un foco de contaminación.
Y quiero poner como ejemplo a mis padres,
quienes trabajaron en el Mercado
de San José de la zona siete,
y que se han dedicado inclusive
a recoger latas y botellas de plástico
para tener un extra y por lo menos
darnos una vida digna.
Y yo, como estudiante
de Ingeniería Química Industrial,
quiero aprovechar todas esas herramientas
que he aprendido con el tiempo,
aprovechar al máximo cada una de ellas
y darles un uso adecuado.
Cada vez escuchamos más noticias tristes
sobre la contaminación del agua.
Cada vez el aire es menos puro
y el suelo se va deteriorando
cada vez más.
Probablemente no me esté afectando a mí,
pero indirectamente puede llegar
a afectar a alguien más.
Pero ojo, no soy sólo yo.
De hecho, muchos de los que están
hoy aquí también tienen ideas
para solucionar este problema,
que es muy triste.
Queremos ser una sociedad
creativa y constructiva.
donde las ideas sean el límite.
Somos producto de una aceleración
de la manufactura de la tecnología,
aunque muchas veces
no la usamos de la mejor manera.
Guatemala es uno de los países
más bonitos del mundo,
y tiene muchos recursos naturales
que todos podemos aprovechar al máximo
He tenido la oportunidad
de trabajar en proyectos
que se dedican al tratamiento de aguas,
y me he dado cuenta
de la complejidad que tienen.
Y es una de las razones por las que muchas
plantas del país están abandonadas
o inclusive no reciben
un mantenimiento correcto.
Perdón por la imprudencia, ya sé que ahora
estamos en momentos de la Covid,
y es justificable.
Pero quiero atreverme a preguntarles
quiénes se bañaron hoy.
Unos cuantos.
La mayoría.
Y de esos, ¿quiénes tardaron
menos de cinco minutos?
La cantidad baja.
Con todo esto no quiero
incentivarlos a que no se bañen,
que algunos son muy ecológicos
y se agradece.
Pero lo que queremos con esto
es que seamos conscientes
de lo que estamos haciendo,
que con la mezcla del tiempo,
la utilidad y los recursos que usamos,
ya sean jabón o acondicionadores
entre otros elementos,
se vuelven cada vez más complejos.
En Alemania, desde hace 70 años,
se prohibe la descarga de aguas residuales
en zonas de agua dulce.
Y además, te cobran por el trato
que le has dado al agua,
con una cuota que va directa a los lugares
donde el agua se purifica.
¿Por qué no aprendemos de ellos?
Te trato como me tratas.
Estudios realizados
por la Universidad del Valle
demuestran que se consumen
unos 222 litros a diario por persona
solamente en la ciudad de Guatemala.
Razón por la cual
muchos no vemos alternativas
para limpiar lo que frecuentamos,
nuestros jardines, los patios, etc.
Sin darnos cuenta de que las comunidades
necesitan este recurso.
Es sabido que en el mundo únicamente
el 2 % del agua es para el consumo humano,
y que de ese 2 %, una gran parte
está retenida en los glaciares árticos.
Es decir, que el agua que podemos consumir
disminuye cada vez más,
y con la contaminación
va disminuyendo mucho más.
Probablemente Uds.
ya conocían estos datos.
Pero ahora ¿qué me toca a mí?
¿Qué puedo hacer yo?
Pues es momento de actuar, ¿no?
En la universidad
hace aproximadamente un año,
quise reunir a un grupo de personas,
compañeras de la carrera,
para crear un grupo de investigación
y ver proyectos que fueran a futuro,
y que inclusive tomaran en cuenta
a las comunidades más vulnerables.
Por eso creamos un plan piloto
en el que se tuviera en cuenta
la fuente de la que se extrae esa agua.
Y por fuente hablamos inclusive
de pozos o lugares como ríos.
Para poder centralizarlos
y dirigirlos por medio de tuberías
para la extracción de sólidos,
ya sean plásticos,
hojas, rocas o lo que sea.
Para pasarlo luego a un proceso denominado
electrólisis, que estará alimentado
por la energía producida
por el ejercicio de las personas.
Tras esto, un filtro por medio de capas,
podrá retener los sólidos
y al final se podrá usar el agua para el
consumo evitando problemas de salud.
Pero ¿de dónde obtendremos esa energía
para alimentar nuestro reactor?
¿Por qué no nos basamos en un concepto
similar al del gimnasio callejero?
Creo que muchos de Uds. lo conocen.
¿Por qué no hacer una modificación
y utilizar todo ese ejercicio
para generar energía,
convertirlo y poder transformarlo?,
Para darle ese proceso
denominado electrólisis,
que puede disminuir los contaminantes
y retribuir a las comunidades.
Claro que todo proyecto necesita saber
cuánto se va a gastar.
Pero en realidad,
al hacer una comparación
con una potabilizadora de agua
nos dimos cuenta de que es muy accesible,
e inclusive puede llegar a ser replicable.
Con todo este proyecto queremos
facilitar una economía circular,
donde les demos a los recursos
que estamos desechando,
una segunda oportunidad
para mejorar la economía.
Creo que cuando hablamos del agua
nos viene a la cabeza un momento triste,
en el que uno va a un río y recuerda
que hace unos cuantos años lo veía
cuando viajaba con su familia
y ahora ya no está
o bien está muy contaminado.
Y es muy triste.
Pero pongámonos ahora en los zapatos
de la gente que usaba ese recurso
bien para alimentarse o incluso para tener
un ingreso extra que ya no tienen.
Por medio de este proyecto que les mostré
estamos evaluando formas
para darle un mejor uso a los recursos
y aprovechar cada uno de ellos.
Si somos el problema,
seamos también la solución.
(Aplausos)